first of all while of course we will  continue to monitor the data we are now  extremely confident that those parts of  the country currently in level four  will move to level three on the 26th of  april that's now  less than two weeks away that means  amongst other things  that on that day shops will fully reopen  pubs cafes and restaurants will  also be able to fully open outdoors on  the 26th of april  and indeed they'll be able to open  indoors on that day albeit on a  restricted basis and it's worth noting  i think that the restricted indoor  opening of hospitality  on the 26th will be actually three weeks  ahead  of any indoor opening of hospitality in  england